normalement au musée les bras chargés
d'oeuvres d'art issue de la collection
des musées de bourges claire s'invite
dans les écoles une façon de maintenir
ce lien précieux entre les enfants et la
culture les jeunes le petit bda doit
être dur parce que cette éthique et
l'avouer les p'tits cracks
on s'est dit que ce serait important de
da2 d'apporter cette chance aux enfants
et d'apporter de la culture aux enfants
mais aussi pour nous ça nous permet de
rester au contact du public parce que ça
reste notre une première une de nos
premières missions c'est quand même de
voilà de transmettre de présenter des
oeuvres le patrimoine au public
eh bien on va je vais essayer de vous
faire deviner en fait à votre avis
qu'est ce que ça peut être cet objet
après avoir découvert des oeuvres
gallo-romaine médiévale ou du 20e siècle
c'est au tour des élèves de s'essayer à
l'art de la sculpture c'est le moment où
les enfants peuvent appréhender la
culture avec les mains en fait plutôt
que de les emmener voir des musées
plutôt que de les poser dans des
vitrines falher permis de créer créer
c'est important pour eux parce que ça
leur fait ça leur fait faire ce lien
avec la culture qu'on al'habitude de
leur proposer à l'école mais de pouvoir
créer pour eux c'est important
créé et se prendre le temps d'un après
midi pour des rodin en herbe dit avoir
fait religieux
le museau
bush alors à valence à ces dieux chargé
mme blais pour prix j'ai rêvé d'en faire
depuis tout petit du coup vous
aujourd'hui c'est que mon rêve s'est
réalisé ce projet pédagogique se
poursuivra toute l'année scolaire dans
les écoles du département du cher la
municipalité souhaite pérenniser ces
rencontres au delà de la crise sanitaire
[Musique]